right uh
well hi everybody welcome to the last
talk of the workshop
so
you've made it
okay and uh
for last but certainly don't not least
yeah we'll have like uh vasil sirganis
from msr
giving talk
uh so vasilis of course he's an he's an
expert in all of the diverse areas of
the workshop so
learning in games machine learning and
economics uh econometrics and so on and
so forth and uh
and also he's uh of course a lead
organizer of the whole semester on
learning games and uh today he will be
giving a
a talk on information auctions
with quick assumptions and information
thank you very much for sitting and um
yours
thanks george for the introduction
so yeah i'll be talking about this paper
which is about the inference of
fundamentals and counterfactuals in in
auctions
uh when we don't want to take a strong
stance about what information people are
uh receiving uh before building in an
option
one motivating example and um
and the data set that we're actually uh
using in this uh in this work is
the
uh
auctions for oil drilling rights
so you know there's this open source
data set that you can also play with
it's it's publicly available
where you get the data from
auctions for drilling rights in
louisiana and texas
and here we're going to restrict
ourselves attention to we're going to
restrict our attention to auctions among
only two bidders
so there are 584 auctions among two
bidders for drilling rights in uh
louisiana and texas these are you know
oil companies that um
uh want to drill for for oil and what we
observe for its data point is a bit per
acreage so every
all tract has some
area in terms of acres people submit
some cumulative bit we translate it into
bit per accurate
so this is roughly the distribution of
bits that you observe in this data set
and the uh typical approach in in this
auction for oil drilling rights is to
think of the auction as a common value
option
so there is this unknown common value
which is how much spoil is in this
tract
and
we're each trying to gather information
maybe with different
technologies that different companies
have before the auction and then we're
going to submit a bid
and the winner wins and and drills for
oil and then discovers what was the
value uh
for that item that was sold
and what we want to understand from this
data set is what is the distribution of
this common value
in this population of auctions that were
run in these two states
so
you know on average how is this uh
value of of all tracks distributed maybe
we can use this information
to set appropriate reserve prices or
maybe redesign
our auction
so we might want to understand
this distribution of the common value or
some summary statistics of that
distribution
so how do we go from this distribution
of bids to the distribution of common
values that's the main question
now in order to be able to do that
you need to make assumptions that will
connect
the distribution of values
that your aux your your bidders know
when they submit a bid
into the distribution of bids
but this mapping from the distribution
of values to distribution of bids is
also heavily dependent on the types of
signals that each player receives prior
to bidding in the auction
so maybe one oil company has different
type of drilling tech of sort of like
inspection technologies than others or
they know something more and they've
inspected and found some more
information about the about the item
and these technologies are typically
secretive technologies you know we don't
know maybe they're uh
proprietary so we don't know what
they're using
so they receive these signals that we
don't observe
in our data neither the auctioneer
observes when running the auction
and the mapping from the distribution of
values the distribution of bits is
heavily dependent to this signaling
structure and this information structure
that happens prior to the auction
so if you want to have some more uh
mathematical formalism we're going to
assume that we have an uh access to data
from a common value option
where value is drawn from some unknown
distribution pi
i will denote the the density
uh so we'll with b we're going to denote
the profile of bits that are being
submitted
we'll assume that the players have
quasi-linear utilities so
their utility will be this unknown value
minus their bid
when they win
it's going to be a first price auction
which is typical in these procurement
auctions
and
prior to the auction
each player receives some signal si
which is dependent on the unknown common
value
and so it's drawn from some distribution
d of v which depends on the unknown
common value v
and then based on that signal
the
bidder submits a bid which depends on
that signal of course it doesn't depend
on the unknown common value because
neither the players know the unknown
common value they only know their signal
and we assume that the data that we
observe is an outcome of some base nash
equilibrium
of this incomplete information game
which means that in expectation if i
condition on my signal
my bid is the best response to any other
bit that i could have submitted
and throughout the talk we'll assume
that bids and values
are discretized so there's a finite
number of bids and a finite number of
values that players will have which will
go into our the technologies that we'll
will develop
so our goal is to perform robust
inference on this distribution of values
without assumptions on the signal
structure that the players receive prior
to the auction because that's something
that's that we do not know it's
proprietary and we don't want to make
some strong
assumptions and then make
non-robust
sensitive inference that is
only valid under those assumptions
uh of course we're going to be
conservative but we want to be sort of
robust all of those
the things that we don't that we do not
know and cannot model
so then if we want to do that
the question is
what are the joint distributions
of
values and bit profiles
that can arise at an equilibrium of the
game under some signaling scheme
um
if from theory we could
from a you know equilibrium theory we
could pinpoint what is the relation
between
what is you know this set of joint
distribution we could pinpoint what is
this conditional distribution of values
conditional on beads
and let's denote that with some density
x
then we can combine it with the observed
b distribution let's call it phi
to get what is the uh the value
distribution right just simple uh
marginalization
right so we're hoping from our uh
you know like auction theory to tell us
what is the space of feasible axis
uh that we that
will arise in this
game under some signaling scheme
so then you know the question the main
question is what is the space of
possible such joint distributions that
are consistent with bayes nas
equilibrium under some some signaling
scheme
and luckily you know before our work
there's this uh beautiful theory by
bergman and morris that exactly
characterizes
what is the space of such
joint distributions that are consistent
with the bayes nash equilibrium for some
signaling scheme
namely what they do is they define the
notion of a base correlated equilibrium
which is a joint distribution over
values and bit profiles
such that if i take an expectation
with respect to that joint distribution
and i condition on my bid
i don't want to deviate to any other
bead
than the one that was designated by this
joint distribution right
so it's a bayesian version of a
correlated equilibrium a particular one
there are many versions of how you can
extend correlated equilibria to games of
incomplete information and this is one
definition
but the beauty of this definition is
that it coincides exactly
with the space of joint distributions
that would arise
at some base nash equilibrium for some
signaling scheme
of this original incomplete information
so um is there a priority
that is incorporated with side does the
margin of sight
equal to that yeah exactly yes i see so
for every prior there is a set of sides
yes so there's this extra consistency
also a requirement
so
so this is the main you know the main
observation that we're gonna also base
our inverse sort of like exercise
and the main contribution of this work
is to use this uh
beautiful masonry-based correlate
equilibria and apply it to the
econometric question and develop an
informationally robust inference process
that boils down to solving a stochastic
linear program
so the main observation main
contribution of this paper is that if
you're searching for the space of all
possible value distributions that are
consistent with the observed
distribution of beads
and such that the observed distribution
of b is a base nasal equilibrium under
some signaling scheme then equivalently
you can ask
what is the space of possible value
distributions that are consistent with
the observed distribution of bids and
such that the joint distribution is a
base correlated equilibrium
the two questions are basically
identical
and so then
you're looking for
such joint distributions that
correspond the base correlated
equilibrium so these fats satisfy all of
these uh best response inequality
constraints for every bit of a player
and every deviating beat
and then the extra thing that happens is
that you want this joint distribution to
also
be a product of the observed
distribution of bids and this marginal
distribution this conditional
distribution of values conditional on
beads
and so the only unknown over here
is this x thing that we do not know
v is something that we observe in the
data
this is coming from the rules of the
auction and so
the x that we were looking for the space
of x's that we were looking for is
exactly the space of x's that satisfy
those inequalities for every i b i and
bi prime
i guess you're taking it out of the
picture here right yeah it's because of
the the theorem of uh
this theorem that you you don't if
you're just looking at the how uh values
and bits correlate with each other
and
that's the um the abstraction at which
you want to look at correlations
uh
this theorem exactly gives you the space
of all possible correlation structures
and you don't need to actually
you know like for every correlation
structure you can find the signaling
scheme that will support it
and vice versa that's what this gives
you so you don't really need to argue
about
the explicit signaling image implicit
there is some kind of construction of a
signaling scheme that will support
the the correlation that that you
certainly
um
you know like it's something like you
you receive a signal that's your beat or
something like that
something right so you
it's like it's like an evaluation type
of principle right so you receive a
single speed up and then
um
all right so um so as i said this is
something that comes from the rules of
the auction let's call it q for
simplicity this is something that you
observe in the data from the big
distribution and this is
the
what x needs to satisfy
and then
once you satisfy those constraints you
can also back out what is the
distribution of values right it's this
another
linear constraint that will give you the
distribution about response
and so this is sort of like if you
want to take one thing away from the
from this paper is that you can do
econometrics that are is robust to
inference this robust informational
assumption by solving this linear
problem
right so this is a linear program uh
where
x v of b conditional b are the end pi of
b are the variables so because we assume
that values and bits are descript
they're going to be as many
variables as the number of values and
the number of bit profiles
and here the number of values from the
values
and
the space of all possible common value
distributions
uh is the space of feasible solutions to
be so
and so the identified set of value
distributions is a set of physical
solutions to this solution
so that's the main framework
uh
there are several given that you know
like
this set of feasible solutions to the
body distribution is given by an lp
there are many
other nice things that you can do with
that
and so
you know the other contribution of the
work is to give you several other things
that you can do with this observation
so let me give you some other things
that you can do
uh one is
that because you know your feasible set
is just a polytope you can minimize or
maximize any linear objective of that
density
and so you can find upper and lower
bounds to any moment of that
distribution by solving a linear program
my previous question
[Music]
is fine now
why is
when you're going the forward direction
like what they rate it like no yeah the
agents are like you know the the very
many more workers more like i give you
some buy what is the feasible uh joint
distributions i should expect is this
joint distribution and also the margin
of pi here we do the reverse we
marginalize on the fee on the
distribution bits and yeah the other
question i was like how
is this how much is this sensitive to
the fact that we don't have perfect
numbers of
distribution 5
if i jiggle this
what is the error in my installation
yeah so that's the inference part i'll
talk about some results on the insurance
part
in the end i'll also mention that i
think a big open question is uh finding
better inference procedures for sub-sale
peace and you'll see what we have
there's been some recent progress on
that
recently seen on archive
i believe even on next week's uh
causality estimation
reading group that's happening on
thursdays there's going to be one paper
that relates to this that peter simerova
will be presenting on partial
identification
um
yeah so
that might be a relevant reading group
so this is we're still in the population
regime where we observe the distribution
of pits right
and all i was saying you can do these
nice other identification exercises you
can find upper and lower bounds on the
identified set you can exactly find the
identified set by solving two linear
programs
another nice thing that you can do is
you can ask counterfactual questions you
can say what if i change the mechanism
or what if i change the rules of the
game in general
and i care about some objective like
revenue or welfare
can you give me some upper and lower
bound of
what that objective would look like in
this new game if i assume that the
players are going to have some other
signalling scheme
in that new game and they're going to
play some base mass equilibrium
so this now boils down to exactly adding
an extra set of constraints and coupling
with the original set of linear
constraints it's going to be a bigger lp
but still you can formulate this upper
and lower bounds as another you know
solving again two linear programs
these linear programs are going to now
have
base correlated equilibrium variables
for the new game sub cycle there will be
a base correlated equilibrium of the new
game
and what you want is to optimize some
objective
sorry not optimized to characterize what
is the value of some objective that
depends on values and bids so it could
be revenue could be welfare
that distribution of joint distribution
should be a base correlated equilibrium
these are these constraints of the new
game which is given by utilde
and this base coordinate equilibrium
should marginalize to the pi of v which
should also satisfy the consistency
requirements that you get from your
original game right and so all of these
are now just linear constraints and you
can solve these two lps and get upper
you know the identified set of some kind
of actual quantity when you change the
mechanism
so you can ask questions you know i'm
running a gsp what if i was running a
first price auction what is the revenue
that i should expect to get right or i'm
running a first price auction what if i
was running a second price auction what
revenues do i expect to get
uh given the data that we that i have
from my first from my first price
auction we're given data from a general
i second price auction what should i
expect by having it to be in a first
price auction without making assumptions
of what signals players receive
either in the original game or in the
new game
the information uh
so yeah good question
so the in this in these kind of actuals
that we had in our work we were allowing
also the information the signaling
scheme to change between the the
original and the counter factual
you can think of it as you know i'm
doing something this year and i'm gonna
deploy a new thing next year my
advertisers are gonna get some new
signals or whatever so that changes but
it's also in many scenarios might also
be interesting to ask what if i couple
the information
the signaling scheme so i constrained
the
signal scheme of my auction of the of
the bidders to be the same in the in the
new and the old mechanism
and this was a question addressed by
follow-up work
for following up to our work bergman
brooks and morris addressed exactly that
question and so it also that even that
counterfactual you can write it as a
linear
set of linear constraints
but basically what happens here is you
need to view
the whole thing as a single game
and now you have a base correlated
equilibrium which submits jointly a bit
in this game in this other game it
should be it's a you know joint base
correlated equilibrium so that's why now
you're going to have you know like
variables that correspond to uh joined
the value and the bid in the new game
uh and so there's going to be some more
intricate coupled constraints how this
variable enters in the new base
correlate equilibrium and in the old
base correlate equilibrium
but you can still use all of these
machinery of lps to address that
question
um other things you can do is you can
add some cons you know constraints on
shape constraints on your density as
long as they fall into some linear set
of constraints so for instance you can
add lipsticks by saying that you know my
the density between two values is not
going to change by much this is another
set of constraints you can throw it in
vlp and optimize subject to such
lip systems constraints so this is if
you want to
sort of narrow beat your
your identified sets
another set of things that you can do is
assume that your
density follows
some parametric family
so what if
i assume that the distribution of values
is some truncated normal or some log
normal distribution
with some parameter then i might want to
find what is the set of feasible
parameters
uh that are consistent with the
observations right so now i'm not
looking about and non-parametric density
i'm looking about a single parameter i'm
trying to find what are the parameters
that are consistent and then you just
add here the constraints for any theta
that is a candidate parameter that you
want to test whether it is consistent or
not
you add the density here for theta and
you check whether this linear program is
feasible
and so for every candidate theta you
have a checker which is a solution to a
linear program a feasibility you know
feasibility of a linear program that
checks whether
that
that parameter theta is feasible so if
you have a two parameter family you can
construct a grid of those parameters and
check everyone everything and you know
you're going to include or not include
the parameter based on this linear
program so this is more computationally
intensive because you're going to solve
a linear program for every grid point
but you know you can also do that and we
do that also in experiments
another thing is you know you might
worry that because you're making
no assumption at all about the signals
of the players you might be getting very
wide identified sets
and so in practice you might want to
restrict a bit
how informative
the signals that the players receive are
so you might want to say that
i don't know exactly what signals they
receive but i believe they receive some
signal that is quite in for at least
this much informative of the common one
and the more informative it is the more
you're going to be connecting bids to
values and the more time the tighter the
uh the identified set is going to be
of course there's limits of how you can
do that while still maintaining the lp
structure
one example that you can do is
uh you know first you need to augment
the whole framework by adding what is
known as these minimal signals
so
apart from the
signals that we do not know you can also
extend the framework of bergamot and
boris and now you know the notion of a
minimal signal where players receive
those minimal signals too and on top of
that they might receive something else
and still you have the same type of base
correlated equilibrium constraints but
now on on top of conditioning on on the
bi you also condition on this minimal
signal ti of every player
um
and again you're like the the signal is
also going to be part of the
fundamentals so you also need to
marginalize the signal and once you
augment the framework with these minimal
signals you can now do things like
saying i believe that the minimal signal
is going to be within epsilon
of the common value
and then it just changes the support of
those uh
linear constraints
that uh the signal that the player
receives should be in the support that's
consistent with a common value and you
know you get tighter linear constraints
so that's one one way you can do that
another way you can do is you can do it
is to say that i believe that you know i
impose that these minimal signals will
follow some uh parametric family so you
know at least the players receive some
normal distribution centered at the
common value and with some variance
sigma squared and on top of that they
might receive something else
and then you know you again get a linear
an extra linear constraint which here q
is a known
coefficient and pi over e is the thing
that you're trying to identify
okay
so this is a way to
incorporate the
informativeness constraints
so these are all the population
quantities all of the identification
strategies and then you
reasonably you you ask
now i don't have this population limit i
don't have this distribution
phi of the of the bid profiles i only
have access to n samples in our ocs data
it was 500 roughly samples
so we observe ensembles of those bit
vectors
and the standard approach is to replace
these expected constraints with an
empirical analog of those
so you know if you view this expected
constraint it's basically an expectation
where here i have an indicator of
whether this random variable b
was equal to the bit profile small b
so my constraints my population
constraints are of this form i have some
expected value of some
quantity where that involves some
randomness omega should be less than or
equal to zero
and what i'll do when i have samples is
replace these expectations with
empirical averages
so i'll
now solve
the empirical version of those
constraints
but in order to account for the fact
that i have error in my empirical
objective and my constraints i will add
some slackness to my constraints to
account for that sampling error
so
you're not going to check whether
they're less than or equal to zero
you're going to check whether they're
less than or equal than some threshold
sigma n which is going to decay to zero
as n goes to infinity
[Music]
you know
it's just gonna be a you're still gonna
get concentration you're not looking at
the conditional
you know
you don't care about like super norms or
consistency of the density
right so you just care about these
averages which
is more benign than learning the density
i guess what i mean
it's very rare so you trust
what you also care is about averaging
right
over
the
it's not going to affect that much the
the bike the when you marginalize on
values
yeah i see that though i guess i would
be more comfortable if you told me like
with this many big vectors here's what
you can get if you want to go there out
of concentration equalities
you can say so you know let's look at
the non-parametric inference where you
don't make any positive and you care
about some moment of the distribution
uh so you minimize over x this empirical
objective uh you know this is just a pi
of uh v right
i took the cons today quality container
put it in the objective
and this is the empirical objective what
you can show is that as long as
sigma n and epsilon n are roughly log
the number of bits
bit vectors
that that you have over delta divided by
the number of samples
then
the
set
corresponds to ln minus epsilon n and
you have plus epsilon n
is going to contain
of the
population l u with probability 1 minus
delta
and also some unit some constants here
are you know what is the magnitude of
negativities is going to be a constant
in front of it that's typical with
concentration inequalities but not many
more constants
and you know here of course you know
you're going to get exponential number
of bit vectors if you have many bidders
but it's inside the log so it's still
going to be
polynomial in the number of bidders
and
so that's one result that you can get um
the number of bid uh the number the the
number of bid profiles
in the support of the distribution of
bids
right all possible bid profile right so
if you have let's say for every bidder
you allow 20
discretized bids and you have 5 bidders
this is going to be 20 to the 5.
and similarly if you if you want to do
like parametric inference so
you're saying
i
assume some parametric family
and i want to
check
whether
some parameter theta is in the
identified set so i want to give you a
a set which is a superset of the three
identified set
uh
and then you're gonna solve exactly the
same types of inequality constraints
with the slackness you're gonna have
this also sort of like equality
constraint with the slackness it's going
to correspond to two inequality
constraints plus and minus which boils
down to a and you know objective of the
you know like a quantity of this form
you're trying to find all of the
parameters theta
such that a minimum over x a max over
all possible constraints all of those
constraints
this empirical analog of the constraint
is going to be less than or equal to
some sigma
so you're trying to
choose sigma n such that when you solve
this you get a set that is a superset of
the identified set
again you can show that if you choose
sigma n to be
log the number of parameters so if you
do a grid
over the parameters and you check all of
those
again number of bit bit vector profiles
number of value vector the number of
common values if you discretize the
common values
if you choose sigma n to be that then
with probability 1 minus delta what
you're going to get is going to be a
superset of the population
identified set
however so these are finite samples of
guarantees with high probability
but what we observed when we tried to
apply this in the data is that typically
these types of sigma and choices the
slackness choices that come out of
concentration inequalities
led to very conservative uh
like very per you know like we're quite
large such that the
the estimated identified set that you're
going to get here is going to be
a very large part of the space so almost
all all part of the space is going to be
your identified set for small samples
right
because you you know you're very
conservative on how these
empirical averages deviate from their
mean
and so we wanted to
also develop
sub-sampling based approaches which are
going to be more
going to be less conservative but will
of course only have uh
asymptotic guarantees and not find
finite sample guarantees
and so here's one thing that we applied
in in the data and worked quite well in
experiments and in the real real data
uh was to develop a subsampling based
uncertainty based on some techniques uh
some generic techniques also in
econometrics
where uh
your goal
is to find
what is the distribution of this worst
case moment violation
among all the parameters that are in the
identified set
so
we're here now we're still in the in the
parametric case so say we have like a
two-dimensional uh you know like a
two-parameter family
um
with some parameters say being the mean
and some other parameter being the
variance or whatever
uh and
our goal is to find what is the you know
the the set of mean and variances that
are uh
uh consistent with the observed data
uh to do that you need to say
if you look at the population identified
set what is the typical violation of the
of the inequality that you
expect to have
on this in the samples for all points
that are in the identified set
in the population limit all those points
should have a a violation that's less or
equal to zero
but in finite samples
uh
there will be one of those points that
will be uh violated so okay so here this
would be the empirical average not the
expectation so you want to look among
all of those points that are in the
population identified set
what is the uh the say the 90 percentile
of the of the violation of uh
of of these moment inequalities when you
go to finite samples in the worst case
over all those parameters in the
identified set
so if you could
get a handle of the distribution of this
random variable again you know i want to
be uh
careful so you replace this with the
empirical
average and so this now is a random
variable
where the samples are the random
variables
and you want to get a hold of this
distribution of this random
variable um
if you could if someone gave you the
distribution of this random variable
then you could choose the say the one
minus delta quantile of that
distribution of violations
as your slackness parameter and you'll
be getting asymptotically
nominal sort of coverage with
probability one minus delta
okay
so this is an asymptotic theorem that
comes from prior work
and so then one thing that you can that
you can do to get a handle of that
distribution is sub sampling
you can construct an initial estimate of
that identified set by say solving
the min max
problem with no slackness this is sort
of like an optimistic
estimate of the identified so it's going
to be very tight
so you
you find the sets data
that satisfy these inequalities without
any slackness on all of the data and
this is sort of your estimate your
initial estimate of this identified set
then you start constructing some samples
of your data
and for every sum sample
you go over that original identified set
and you find the maximum violation like
the violation in the lp
a violation that would make the lp
feasible
so for all possible
parameters in that set you solve the lp
and you find its solution you know like
in order to satisfy the lpn that's on
that subsample for all though for these
parameters you need like a slackness of
you know epsilon one excellent two
epsilon three epsilon four that's what
you're gonna get this tau sorry this tau
is going to be what you're going to get
from every sub sample the worst case
violation of those inequalities for
those parameters in the original theta
hat
and then you can use the one minus delta
quantile of those quantities
over the
subsamples that's going to be a proxy
for the you know those quantities are
going to be the empirical distribution
of those quantities over subsamples
assuming the subsample size is a little
of the original sample size is going to
be
a good proxy for how this
this random variable over here is
distributed and so a 1 minus delta
quantile of this empirical distribution
is going to be sort of consistent with
that quantile that you care about
and then you can if you want to be more
accurate you can then go back and re
recompute the identified cell with this
slackness
this is going to give you a wider
set of parameters
and then you can go back and repeat this
but this wider set of parameters until
you get some convergence where you know
by doing that your identified set is not
enlarged more and more right
so that is the subsampling based process
and this is these are the two things
that we applied in the data
uh first you know we did some synthetic
experience
go ahead
sorry i'm trying a little bit to
understand so
i have the maximum loss over some
functions uh okay i am applying
minimizes i'm trying to understand if
that problem is a
max mean of the convex conjugate
function well
well
the internal thing mean x over max j is
just an lp right right they agree i
agree because here is a grid right so
this you go over those uh points in the
grid of theta
oh
it's just a green you know you'll see
some grid in the next slide right you
just so i see this point right and you
solve an lp for all of those points on
every sub sample and you you just take a
maximum over those right
this whole thing is uh
yeah
okay thank you very very much great
yeah so here is one you know like who is
yesterday
of correlation between the fact that
depends on the data set but
there is like the s is sampled from the
same data
[Music]
this part is not very rigorous and most
of the firms are asymptotic so i i don't
have something clever to say about that
ideally you would want to sample split
but
yeah okay
so i think one of my questions is
getting more uh robust and formal
guarantees for these types of
sub-sampling procedures there are you
know like if you go to the literature
there are synthetic consistency rates
not rates as not consistent properties
but
yeah
so um
first we start with some synthetic
experiments to understand uh how these
uh different you know uncertainty
quantification approaches work
um
over here the first thing we try to do
is okay how much do you gain or lose in
terms of like identification power when
we when you don't assume any parametric
distribution
so each one of those uh
[Music]
pictures is a is the
a different parametric distribution so
we generated data where we drew the
value from some
parametric distribution like a gaussian
or poisson or binomial
then we calculated some base correlated
equilibrium for the bidders for some
signal which corresponds to some
signaling scheme we then drew bid
profiles from that base correlate
equilibrium and we asked you know what
is the identified set given this bit
profile
so here we are in the population limit
so we actually you know you calculate
the base correlated equilibrium in terms
of like exact distributions and that's
what you
then feed into your inverse lp program
uh and so these are population
quantities
so you see here that um
the brown is if you really if you also
assume that the in the inverse
problem that your
distribution is gaussian
you'll get an identified set that is
this brown thing in terms of like the
identified set for the mean and the
standard deviation of the distribution
of values
if you don't assume and you go after a
parameter a non-parametric
specification
then you're going to get the green thing
so the identified set is going to be
quite larger but not that large you
don't get like everything without making
the parametric assumption
and the same thing is what we depict in
the other ones
so it can buy you a lot of stuff if you
uh make a parametric assumption and it's
correct as well specified but of course
you might have missed specification
problems
the other thing you we wanted to
understand how conservative are the
concentration inequality approaches
and so over here you see that uh
if you so with brown
is the parametric identified set that
was also showing the previous slide
and with green is the non-parametric
estimated set when you add the slackness
that are coming from concentration
equalities
so if you want the rigorous finite
sample guarantee this is the set that
you're going to get the green one
even when n is equal to a thousand and
you need to go to n equals roughly
one million samples to get something
that's sort of reasonable looking
um
the
you know
and then we also wanted to you know look
at how subsampling behaves which is
going to be a bit more much less
conservative so it might not include the
whole set that's going to be much
tighter
uh on the left again you see this the
same figures
as before but in a difference of like xy
space but it's the concentration
equality type of figures over here you
see the subsampling based approach
where with green is the
estimated identified set
when we have 100 samples we use a sub
sample of size 25 and we draw 50 sub
samples in that process that i described
and so we get a much tighter
confident confidence set which includes
the brown thing which we want to include
and similarly for n equals 500 we get
even tighter over here you see that you
know sometimes you might be losing the
brown thing you might be
losing some of those points so this is a
grid over here we've greeted those uh
parameter points and so we you test
every one of those so you might be
missing some of those grid points from
the brown
so
you're less conservative but you're much
tighter and with 99
confidence sets you typically always
include the
truth
similarly if you project on the mean
of the distribution you get
that you always include the beam
the true mean
uh also then you know signal signal
constraints can buy you something
this is
the population identified set with and
without signaling
informativeness constraints so here is
the more stringent one where we assume
somehow that the readers receive signals
that is with one within two
gridded bit points
gridded the points from the true value
so
epsilon equals two means like they get a
very informative signal epsilon equals
20 they get a very uninformative signal
and we see that you know you get a point
identification when you assume very
informative signals and you get
weaker you know partial identification
if you
don't make that assumption
and going back to the ocs data
these are the
identified sets that we were recovering
so with uh with brown over here is sort
of like the zero tolerance set so this
is sort of like what i was saying is the
uh the optimistic theta hat where if you
solve uh find the points that
satisfy all of the constraints with less
than or equal to zero
and with green is what you get after the
quantile process where you can enlarge
it by taking some samples and then
resolving the lp but with this larger
slackness
and again you can get some benefit by
adding
signaling constraints this is a much
coarser grid due to computational
constraints
but you know if you add some
informativeness constraints you can get
tighter identified sets
we have several extensions to uh private
value auctions and we've applied it also
to sponsor search data
and uh
you know the whole framework applies to
general games of incomplete information
with discretized action and type spaces
so you can apply to your favorite game
of incomplete information
uh one uh noteworthy application we did
was in sponsored search
where uh this was a private value
exercise
where we looked at uh trying to recover
the
mean of the distribution of the com of
the private value of every bidder for
instance we looked at 12 keywords and
the top three bidders on those keywords
and try to find the confidence sets for
the mean of their private value
the main reason we did that was to try
to understand do we really get uh
humongous confidence or this this very
robust but quite conservative inference
strategy giving us something meaningful
and you see that you don't get
like sort of null sets that are between
0 and 20. so the numbers here are
normalized to lie between 0 and 20 and
you get quite informative sets
for each of those bitters and keywords
and you can even get somewhat
informative sets if you do counter
factual evaluation so we did one
exercise of counterfactual evaluation
where we're saying suppose that you were
running among the two top two bidders of
the auction
now a first price auction with only one
slot what is the revenue in that option
so that's the counterfactual we did
and you get bonds on the revenue some
bounds are
quite uninformative uh
again this should be ranging between
zero and uh and
20 i believe so you get here some
keywords where the revenue bound that
you get is between 0 and 10 which is you
know too
uninformative
but you know
you get
conservative information of what your
revenue could be under if you switch to
the first price auction and if for some
of those keywords you get definitive
information that is going to be better
than your current revenue under gsp
you're safe to sort of switch to that
assuming that bidders will respond
so that was the
that was the work uh you know the main
conclusion is that we offer an inference
process for
fundamental and counterfactual
quantities that is robust information
assumptions in general games of
incomplete information with discretized
action and type spaces
in a manner that can be phrased as a
solution to a stochastic linear program
you can incorporate many constraints and
variants such as shape constraints
parametric distribution and signal
informativeness
uh we developed a concentration equality
based approach to finite sample
inference and a subsampling based
approach with asymptotic distribution
guarantees
of coverage
i think one main open question is
getting better uncertainty set methods
that are
as tight as the subsampling approaches
in the asymptotic limit but with better
and provable finite sample guarantees
thank you very much
thank you thank you
questions from the audience
[Music]
this is what i meant and for example one
question is uh if you just do a
bootstrap subsampling uh can you prove
uh fine example
uh rates of the bootstrap distribution
and how it converges or do you need to
maybe you could do like some smoothening
of the main max
objective
that would make a bootstrap work and
then appropriately take
some
some limits or whether you know you
maybe you want to change a little
criteria to be no to not be very
unstable like a min max objective
uh so that the bootstrap will be
consistent and then uh well control it
for the box
so showing that some some form of
bootstrap works in this setting and
giving finite example
uh you know
weights on how the distribution of the
bootstrap converges to the true
distribution is an interesting question
[Music]
most of the talk i think was about
common values and then in the end you
said it worked for independent private
values and i didn't know where kind of
the math changed or like did it go as
far back as the bayes correlated
equilibrium or yes it changes from the
very beginning but with more notation
like instead of just having a single
value you have a vi for every feeder
you can also show that you can decompose
the lp to be
only constraints for the vi of a
particular beta if you have independent
private values so then it becomes a
similar lp as the base coordinate
equilibrium but you have a vi for every
bidder separate and a joint distribution
of bits b
and more generally you can do it for any
incomplete information game
where you have some
minimal signaling structure t you have
some fundamentals
fundamental vector v
which
maybe some of them you know like some of
that vector the players observe like in
a private value they observe their part
of the
value vector
or some they don't observe and so there
is an you know like what external
information they observe is part of the
signaling stream that you're robust to
so that's the
generality of the framework yeah
question
so when the num the
number of parameters is too large to
afford a grid search uh do you have any
idea of what you could do could you do
like uh for instance
optimization um by
doing implicit differentiation from yeah
i would suspect that then more like
quasi-bayesian procedures would be
things that you that would work where
you do some sort of monte carlo where
this is the your criteria is this min
max thing and you do sampling and you're
like some you know maybe land giving or
whatever you know dynamics to sample
from that some form of like that would
be would give you a rough approximation
of the identified set we try to traverse
the space and sample from the
space
but of course now your objective will be
an lp so it might be a bit
complicated evaluating your objective
right your objective will be this min
max criterion
so
your the thing that goes into your
quasi-bayesian
you know like likelihood is uh is a
minimax thing
so that you know
but that would be my my go-to
so are there any conditions back to the
question i asked at some point during
the talk like are there any conditions
under which like if you saw this lp
you have confidence in uh
from samples you have confidence in the
mapping from
bit vectors to
the x function the x the x thing or that
you have consistency in the x yeah i've
never explored that i haven't looked at
that at all uh because
yeah for the the quantities that you
care you don't need consistency i
understand but in principle you might
care about that
i don't know
but that quantity is the x is like super
partially identified right that whole
mapping right it's
all possibly the whole politico in some
sense you know it's a very unless you
project it into some dimension
it's a very complicated uh so first
partially identified it's not a single
function right so it's a space of all
possible sort of functions or rather
discretized functions so it's a space of
if you think of uh
for every beat you have a vector that is
the number of value values that you have
and
so that is the dimension of your
polytope the dimensionality of the space
and you're trying to find the polytope
in that dimensional space
um
i don't know it's it's a
very high dimensional object and
the beauty is that you you don't want to
characterize that very high dimensional
quality of object you the quantities
that you care about the simple
projections of it
right yeah
i don't know
i guess you know in the sense of like i
see people bidding and i want to
understand
what's the probability this oil field
has a lot of
stuff underneath yeah but i think for
that you the this type of exercise won't
give you anything because you're not
making
assumptions about what signals they
receive yes i guess that was my question
yes so it's not about sampling it's more
like about even in the population the
assumptions you're making are not strong
enough to give you particular uh to give
you information about those types of
quantities
very nice talk
so in your work you've also done another
papers work about econometrics with
learning agents is there any way to
combine these two fragment works here
and
yeah i mean one uh
one interesting topic would be to if you
go to base course correlate equilibria
they have some connection
to not regret learning in complete
information games and so you could
potentially try to extend these things
to
inference under base course correlated
equilibrium would be which would
correspond to what if my agents
play no regret
like some contextual bonded algorithm
where the context is their signal and
you
don't
make any assumption about what algorithm
and that would converge to the space of
course correlate base course correlated
equilibria and then you're doing
inference under that
but is there like a similar
characterization theorem for that class
[Music]
yes i mean you will have a paper with
json hardline and avatardos
some eurips 2017 that gives you the
notion of base quartz correlated
equilibrium that corresponds to those
limit distributions and it would be an
you know i i can't recall it over here
if
it has any constraint that won't be a
linear program i believe it won't help
that's something
okay that's it let's thank vasily and
all of the speakers once again thank you